« Pourquoi certaines personnes sont racistes ? »
Une autre élève, appelons-la Abby,
avait levé la main et proposé :
« Peut-être que certains n'aiment pas les Noirs
car leur peau est de la couleur du caca. »
Oui, je sais.
A cet instant, toute la classe a explosé.
La moitié d'entre eux a commencé à rire
et l'autre à crier sur Abby
et à dire des choses comme :
« Tu ne peux pas dire ça, c'est raciste ! »
Prenez une seconde pour vous représenter cette scène.
Une classe d'enfants de neuf et dix ans,
la moitié d'entre eux sont hilares
car ils pensent qu'Abby a dit quelque chose d'extrêmement drôle
et l'autre moitié lui crie dessus pour avoir dit quelque chose d'offensant.
Puis il y a Abby, assise là, complètement abasourdie
car elle ne comprend pas le poids de ce qu'elle vient de dire
et pourquoi tout le monde réagit ainsi.
Puis il y a moi, l'enseignante,
me tenant dans un coin, sur le point d'avoir une crise de panique.
En tant qu'enseignante,
je dois constamment prendre des décisions en un quart de seconde.
Je savais que je devais réagir, mais comment ?
Considérez votre instinct de lutte ou de fuite.
Je pouvais lutter en élevant la voix et en la réprimandant pour ses mots.
Ou fuir -- changer le sujet
et vite chercher autre chose,
n'importe quoi pour détourner mes élèves du mot « caca ».
Mais nous le savons, ce qu'il faut faire n'est souvent pas ce qui est facile.
Même si je voulais que ce moment prenne fin
et je savais que ces deux options m'aideraient à échapper à la situation,
je savais que c'était un moment d'apprentissage
trop important pour le laisser passer.
Après m'être tenue là pour ce qui sembla une éternité,
je suis sortie de mon blocage, me suis tournée vers la classe et ai dit :
« L'argument d'Abby est valide. »
Mes étudiants se sont regardés, confus.
J'ai continué :
« Une des raisons pour lesquelles le racisme existe
est que les personnes à la peau claire ont regardé ceux à la peau foncée
et ont dit que leur peau était laide.
Ils utilisent même cette raison comme une excuse pour les déshumaniser.
La raison pour laquelle nous étudions la race et le racisme
est justement d'avoir des connaissances.
Et comprendre pourquoi de tels commentaires sont blessants
et s'assurer que les gens à la peau foncée
sont toujours traités avec respect et gentillesse. »
C'était une situation vraiment terrifiante.
Mais au fil de la conversation,
j'ai remarqué qu'Abby et le reste des enfants
étaient encore désireux de participer.
Alors que je regardais la conversation mariner entre mes élèves,
je me suis demandé combien d'élèves avaient des présomptions comme Abby.
Que se passe-t-il quand ces présomptions ne sont ni remarquées ni abordées,
comme cela arrive souvent ?
Il est d'abord important de prendre du recul
et de considérer ce qui fait qu'un sujet est tabou.
Je n'ai pas reçu de liste officielle de choses
dont on n'est pas censé parler.
Je me souviens avoir entendu à maintes reprises en grandissant :
« Il y a deux choses dont on ne parle pas lors de réunions de famille.
Ces deux choses sont la religion et la politique. »
J'ai toujours trouvé cela curieux
car la religion et la politique sont souvent des facteurs très influents
sur nombre de nos identités et de nos croyances.
Ce qui rend un sujet tabou,
c'est ce sentiment de malaise qui survient
quand ces choses sont abordées durant une conversation.
Certaines personnes parlent couramment la langue de l'équité
alors que d'autres ont peur d'un rappel au politiquement correct
ou que leur ignorance soit révélée dès qu'ils ouvrent la bouche.
Mais je crois que la première étape pour tenir des conversations
sur des sujets tels que l'équité
est d'établir un langage commun.
Cela commence en arrêtant la stigmatisation de sujets
qui sont généralement considérés comme tabous.
Les conversations au sujet de la race, par exemple,
ont un langage spécifique et propre
et les élèves doivent parler couramment ce langage
afin d'avoir ces conversations.
Les écoles sont souvent le seul endroit
où les élèves se sentent libres et à l'aise
pour poser des questions et faire des erreurs.
Malheureusement,
tous les élèves ne ressentent pas ce sentiment de sécurité.
Je savais ce jour-là, devant mes CM1,
que mon choix de réponse pourrait avoir des répercussions à long terme
non seulement pour Abby,
mais pour le reste des élèves.
Si j'avais écarté ses mots,
le reste de la classe aurait pu supposer
que ce genre de commentaire est acceptable.
Mais si j'avais crié sur Abby
et l'avais mise en difficulté devant tous ses amis,
ce sentiment de honte associé à l'une de ses premières conversations sur la race
aurait pu l'empêcher de jamais engager le dialogue sur ce sujet.
Enseigner l'équité aux enfants à l'école ne leur apprend pas quoi penser.
Il s'agit de leur donner les outils, les stratégies, le langage
et les opportunités pour s'entraîner à réfléchir.
Pensez par exemple à comment nous enseignons aux enfants à lire.
Nous ne leur donnons pas des livres.
Nous commençons par décomposer des mots en lettres et en sons
et les encourageons à pratiquer leur aisance en lisant tous les jours
avec un partenaire ou avec leurs amis.
Nous leur posons plein de questions de compréhension
pour nous assurer qu'ils comprennent ce qu'ils lisent.
Je crois que l'enseignement de l'équité aux enfants
devrait être approché de la même façon.
J'aime commencer en donnant chaque année un questionnaire à mes élèves
sur des différents sujets liés à l'équité et l'inclusion.
Voici un exemple de questionnaire d'une de mes élèves
et, comme vous le voyez, elle a un peu d'humour.
Pour « Qu'est-ce que la "race" ? »
elle a écrit : « Quand des voitures, personnes et animaux courent
le plus rapide gagne »,
[NdT : race signifie aussi course en anglais]
Cependant, si vous regardez la question « Qu'est-ce que le racisme ? »,
elle dit : « Quand quelqu'un insulte quelqu'un ayant la peau foncée ».
Elle est jeune, mais elle montre qu'elle commence à comprendre.
Quand nous agissons
comme si nos élèves n'étaient pas capables d'avoir ces conversations,
nous leur causons du tort.
Je sais que ce genre de conversations
peuvent sembler très, très intimidantes à avoir avec nos élèves,
surtout les plus jeunes.
Mais j'ai enseigné du CP au CM2
et je peux vous dire, par exemple,
que je ne vais pas entrer dans une classe de CP
et parler de choses telles que l'incarcération de masse.
Mais même un CP de six ans peut comprendre la différence
entre ce qui est juste -- les gens ayant ce dont ils ont besoin.
Nous avons identifié nombre de ces choses ensemble en classe.
La différence entre juste et équitable --
quand tout le monde a la même chose,
surtout les cadeaux aux anniversaires.
Les CP peuvent également comprendre la différence
entre une punition et une conséquence.
Toutes ces choses sont des concepts fondamentaux
que tous doivent comprendre
avant d'avoir une conversation
au sujet de l'incarcération de masse aux États-Unis.
Certains pensent peut-être que les maternelles ou les CP
sont trop jeunes pour avoir des conversations sur le racisme
mais vous disent aussi que les enfants
comprennent que de nombreux éléments composent nos identités,
que les gens sont à la fois similaires et différents
et ce que cela signifie d'avoir du pouvoir quand les autres n'en ont pas.
En ayant ces conversations avec les élèves à un jeune âge,
cela peut en partie annihiler l'impression de tabou
quand ces sujets sont abordés plus tard.
Je sais aussi qu'enseigner ces choses dans les écoles
peut ressembler à la traversée d'un champ de mines.
Par exemple, que se passe-t-il si les parents ou les familles
ne veulent pas que ces conversations aient lieu à l'école ?
A ces personnes, je peux dire :
voici des exemples de choses que les élèves m'ont dites
et ont portées à mon attention.
Par exemple, un élève m'a chuchoté :
« J'ai entendu tous ces gens utiliser le terme LGBTQ
mais je ne sais pas ce que cela signifie et je suis trop gêné pour l'admettre. »
Un élève est venu me voir durant un week-end et m'a dit :
« Je viens de regarder ce film au sujet de l'Australie
et je me demande s'il y a aussi du racisme là-bas. »
Je veux que mes élèves se sentent à l'aise pour avoir ces conversations
car quand ils sont à l'aise pour en parler et poser des questions,
ils deviennent à l'aise pour introduire leurs propres vie et expériences
dans leur relation à ces grands sujets.
Certains enseignants peuvent être nerveux
si un élève aborde un sujet ou pose une question
dont ils ne connaissent pas la réponse.
Mais si un élève porte à mon attention quelque chose
dont je ne connais pas la réponse,
je vais toujours l'admettre
car je ne vais pas prétendre être une experte sur un sujet
où je n'ai aucune expérience et ne suis pas une autorité.
La même année, un élève est venu
et m'a posé une question sur la communauté LGBTQ.
Je n'en savais pas assez pour lui donner une réponse adaptée.
Et donc, j'ai encouragé cet élève
à contacter et poser cette question à un représentant d'une organisation
qui était intervenu dans notre classe sur ce sujet même.
Quand nous admettons à nos élèves que nous n'avons pas toutes les réponses,
non seulement cela nous humanise à leurs yeux,
cela leur montre que les adultes ont aussi du chemin à faire
quand il s'agit d'étudier des questions telles que l'équité.
Il y a quelque temps, j'ai écrit un cours sur le consentement.
Pour certains, cela était très enthousiasmant
car j'ai pris ce sujet qui semblait tabou et effrayant
et je l'ai décomposé afin qu'il soit accessible à de jeunes élèves.
Cependant, pour d'autres,
l'idée du consentement est si fortement liée au sexe
et le sexe est considéré comme un sujet tabou,
que cela les a mis très mal à l'aise.
Mais mes élèves sont en CE2,
nous ne parlons pas de sexe en classe.
Je veux plutôt qu'ils comprennent
que tout le monde a des limites physiques différentes
les mettant mal à l'aise.
L'intelligence sociale et émotionnelle qu'il faut
pour lire les mots, le ton, le langage non verbal de quelqu'un
sont des compétences qu'il faut enseigner explicitement,
comme nous enseignons la lecture et les maths.
Cette leçon n'est pas réservée à des élèves d'un segment démographique.
Le questionnement, l'observation
et la pensée critique
sont des choses que tout élève, peu importe sa race, son ethnie,
son origine, sa langue, son revenu, son code postal,
devrait apprendre à l'école.
Éviter délibérément ces conversations
en dit long à nos élèves
car les enfants remarquent quand les enseignants, les manuels,
omettent les voix et expériences des femmes ou des personnes de couleur.
Le silence en dit long.
Récemment, j'ai demandé à ma classe de CE2
ce qu'ils diraient à des adultes qui les pensent trop jeunes
pour étudier des questions liées à l'équité.
Si ce n'est qu'un petit éventail de mes 25 élèves,
ils étaient tous d'accord
qu'ils sont non seulement capables d'avoir ces conversations
mais ils voient le droit d'étudier cela comme un droit et non un privilège.
Comme ils l'ont dit :
« Nous sommes assez grands pour savoir ces choses
car ces problèmes arrivent là où nous vivons.
Nous avons le droit d'en parler
car cela fera partie de notre vie à l'avenir. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)